la dernière malédiction de la droite sur
le plan chronologique a pour nom
emmanuel macron son accident fillon il
n'y aurait peut-être pas eu d'événement
macro
[Musique]
la malédiction de la droite c'est un peu
une manière de re lire toute l'histoire
de la droite sous la vème république
donc à partir de 1958 en reprenant
j'avais un centre d'événements qui ont
marqué cette histoire est l'événement
qui sont plutôt de nature sinon tragique
du moins difficile pour elle la droite
au fond est est frappé par trois
malédiction la première c'est celle de
la division qui a conduit ses dirigeants
régulièrement à s'affronter voire à se
battre giscard chirac chirac balladur
les épisodes sont nombreux deuxième
addiction ma d'élections idéologique
c'est à dire son incapacité à fédérer en
même temps une sensibilité plus
souverainiste avec une sensibilité
européenne une sensibilité plus libérale
avec une sensibilité plus régaliennes
enfin troisième malédiction plus
profonde peut-être cela une médication
historique
finalement quand on regarde son histoire
on se rend compte que la droite ne
s'aiment pas elle-même qu'elle a
toujours fait un complexe par rapport à
son identité et même par rapport à son
nom elle l'a rarement ou tout cas
tardivement voulu s'assumer comme étant
pleinement de droite ça l'a conduit
souvent à la défaite
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai que l'idée de ce livre
est venue de cette défaite de 2010 est
parce que on l'a beaucoup dit l'élection
de 2017 était pour la droite l'élection
imperdable à droite et à travers celui
qu'elle avait désigné françois fillon
devait logiquement gagné et cet épisode
casque à fonctionner comme une véritable
déflagration a conduit à ce que
l'ensemble du paysage politique soit
soit reconfigurer soit bouleversée et
que la droite en tout cas la droite
partisane connaissent le destin que l'on
a vu avec cet échec
fort des élections des élections
européennes moyens livre qui m'avait
beaucoup marqué lorsque j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à la politique c'était la
double méprise le livre de catherine nay
qui racontait la guerre giscard chirac
est vraiment l'exemple même d'une d'une
rivalité personnelle à l'état brut
[Musique]
mais je pense que les clés de
compréhension c'est que au fond et ça on
le voit à travers toute l'histoire de la
vème république
au fond la droite ne s'aiment pas elle
même
[Musique]